on soit rachid dhibou aves d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à voir ces
manifestations qui sont devenus en tout
cas ces rassemblements devant l'hôpital
robert debré qui sont devenues un rendez
vous hebdomadaire tous les jeudis
pourquoi maintenir cette pression alors
que le ségur de la santé continue vous
n'avez toujours absolument pas confiance
comment se passent les négociations
écoutez pour nous les négociations à se
passe même pas du tout puisque ont été
sollicités pour ouverture du ségur et
ensuite laissé sur le côté
donc aujourd'hui on est on est dans le
flou complet on ne sait pas du tout ce
qui s'y passe on aimerait bien apporter
notre expertise et à nous sommes en
train d'organiser avec une organisation
de collectifs et d'associations
d'infirmiers 1 contre ségur donc nous on
la paie du kent
on s'organise pour essayer d'envoyer une
délégation au niveau du ségur pour pour
apporter pour poser nos revendications
et notre expertise
alors il y aura évidemment la grande
journée du 16 juin qu'est ce qui est
prévu qu est-ce que vous en attendez de
cette journée on espère une forte
mobilisation que ce soit des soignants
et des usagers mais pour nous il ya un
gros souci à l'heure actuelle c'est les
assignations abusive
c'est à dire que les directions sont en
train de priver les soignants à d'un
droit fondamental qui est de droit de
grève
et aujourd'hui on a eu des remontées du
terrain assez impressionnante oudéa des
personnels sont assignés à 100 %
notamment dans les blocs opératoires ce
qui est pour nous impensable
alors expliquez nous concrètement ça
veut dire que vous accusez vous
reprochez votre direction de vous
mobiliser au travail durant cette
journée du 16 juin c'est ça alors que
vous voudriez manifester c'est
exactement ça dans l'établissement il
existe des protocoles de grève
quand il ya une grève on doit assigner
un certain nombre de prix de personnes à
skis ça va le service minimum en théorie
est aujourd'hui les directions font
carrément les jeux contraire
c'est-à-dire qu'elle désigne tout
personnel et prive les les soignants de
leur droit de grève alors il ya
peut-être d'autres bâtons dans les roues
je ne sais pas je vais vous laisser
juger on va écouter christophe castaner
le ministre de l'intérieur qui était
interviewé sur une chaîne d'information
justement sur ces droits à manifester en
pleine crise sanitaire on rappelle les
règles pas plus de 10 personnes dans
l'espace public en ce moment égouttez la
réponse il faut que les manifestations
soient déclarés il est important aussi
de rappeler le droit mais surtout les
conditions sanitaires
les personnels soignants le savent mieux
que d'autres
une manifestation aujourd'hui c'est
prendre le risque de diffuser le virus
évidemment en ligne de mire aussi cette
manifestation du 16 juin la
manifestation c'est prendre le risque de
diffuser le risque du virus vous êtes
bien passé pour ce one est ce virus
qu'est ce que vous répondez au ministre
de l'intérieur
si on est très bien placé après quand on
appelle à la manifestation on appelle
également à tous les gestes barrières
aux mesures sanitaires qui s'impose
c'est un fait
aujourd'hui on sait que le virus est
enfin en train de diminuer au niveau de
son ca contagion
donc pour nous appliqués les gestes
barrières et les limites de
distanciation nous permettrait d'aller
manifester en bonne et due forme
justement sur cette manifestation est ce
que on imagine évidemment elle va être
déclarée est ce qu'elle va être
autorisée nous avait des craintes que ça
puisse mal voilà tournée comme ces
manifestations qu'on a vu la semaine
dernière contre les violences policières
présumées par exemple je pense que
depuis le début toutes les
manifestations de soignants ont été très
pacifique
il ya eu très peu de débordements de la
part des soignants nature-là la même
ligne de conduite aujourd'hui on n'est
pas en opposition avec les forces de
l'ordre aux autres on est là pour
réclamer nos droits et et imposer nos
revendications qui qui je pense
intéresse également bain tout le public
et les forces de l'ordre y compris
effectivement les revendications on en a
parlé tout à l'heure on en parle chaque
jeudi on va peut-être consacrer quelques
secondes allait rappeler quels sont les
très grandes urgences pour vous cdc
remettre des moyens humains et
financiers à l'hôpital a arrêté les
fermetures de lits et les fermetures
d'hôpitaux
revaloriser les salaires des soignants
qui était le rappelle sont parmi les
plus bas de l'oscd et remettre surtout
le patient au coeur du système de soins
qui est aujourd'hui on a tendance à
l'oublier
on est plutôt dans des logiques
comptables aujourd'hui malheureusement
que tu prioriser le patient vous avez
aussi également déposé plainte contre
les directions de 32 hôpitaux de france
dont le chu de toulouse pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui à cause du
manque de masques
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ces
plaintes on attend un retour et que les
responsables soient jugés
aujourd'hui il ya eu il ya eu des
manquements et on a on a fait face ont
été mis en danger
réellement on a tous on a tous eu
étaient en pénurie de moyens de
protection à un moment donné dans notre
exercice
donc aujourd'hui ses fans il faut les
gommer pour qu'à l'avenir si une crise
une épidémie de ce même type revient
qu'on soit équipée et qu'on puisse faire
face nous les soignants donc c'est pour
ça on montables du point un petit peu
sur la table pour que les responsables
soient soient jugés et qui est qui et
les torts ne soient pas partagées merci
beaucoup aux arachides indigo à
président du collectif interlock d'avoir
été avec nous en direct assure rt france